ferrand de chaque femme et il faut
respecter le caractère vous êtes charlie
adam qu'est ce qui vous est arrivé chez
n'a franchement j'ai pas j'ai pas
d'anecdotes j'ai une anecdote et je suis
désolé mais c'est sûr pierre ménès non
on était ensemble à la radio mais c'est
pour ça qu'aujourd'hui moi je vois pas
un prédateur sexuel je voyais un
personnage un peu bourru véritablement
maladroit je cautionne absolument pas ce
qu'il fait mais on est à la radio en
centre cyrille on l'avait reçu un mat
avec moi oui on était ensemble
j'étais là oui vous étiez l'armée pour
vous n'avez rien entendu le matin
j'étais tombé bah oui et on vote contre
je sais pas ce qu'on avait dû faire
encore un pari ou quoi que ce soit mais
il y avait une de mes chaussures qui
était posée sur un compteur à la radio
en fait il est arrivé il a pris ma
chaussure il a dit qu'est ce que c'est
que cette chaussure deux aces et plus
loin voilà ce que ça ne suscite que vous
imaginez et ensuite je suis arrivé dans
le studio et il m'a vu il m'a dit ah bah
tiens ça doit être à elle puisqu'elle a
la tête qui va avec
pour la voie là et j'ai trouvé ça mais
d'une violence mais en même temps j'ai
pas été choqué après j'ai pas mal vécu
une chose ok maintenant mais oui mais
avec ces six mois je me suis dit mais
mon pote on n'a pas élevé les cochons
ensemble pour que tout d'un coup elle
est devenue point qu'après non mais on
est on est pas devenu bâtiment voyais un
sms le le soir même en me demandant
emmenant dans un petit peu avec humour
si je voulais aller voir à boire un
verre avec lui par exemple et voilà
mais aujourd'hui je viens là ça y est
rechargée audi j'étais à la radio et
tiffany je vous le jure et et j on
citera bien sûr pas de nom il ya huit
invités sur dix qui vend des actifs a
dit dan fani c'est alors on dit la
vérité oui c'est vrai j'étais invité sur
10 le lendemain matin chaque jo a mis
les bas tu sais pas quoi celui qu'on a
reçues
à ces satanés laquelle est devenu
alcoolique et non me voilà c'est là mais
ce qui est important mais c'est vrai
qu'on viendrait au témoin n'achetons ça
vous est déjà arrimée oui ça m'est
arrivé les rois je vais donc là des
choses concrètes des couturiers des
photographes est expliqué ici ppda par
exemple quand je vous ai dit qu'il m'a
entre deux portes après une émission il
a été relevé mais on en venait à
méconnaître les histoires à mes hôtes et
nous mais on est conduit en fait on j'ai
dit ben non merci
dégage en fait non mais on comprend pas
c'est quoi l'histoire et ppda j'étais
venu pour la promo d'un mailing dans une
de ses émissions qui s'appelait à
l'époque vol de nuit la commission très
prestigieuse et à la fin de l'émission
c'était mon premier roman j'ai été très
impressionné à la fin de l'émission il
est venu il m'a suivi d'une manière
assez voilà insistante il m'a suivi et
entre les deux portes du studio donc de
tf1 il m'a dit ce serait bien qu'on se
revoie vous êtes charmante ont pour
aller prendre un verre
il était assez proche de moi et je me
suis reculé jeudi non merci on se verra
pour mon deuxième livre voilà
point barre d'accord il est d'autres
concerts conscience que vous étiez dans
la mode aussi vous avez eu d un petit
peu mais rien de rien rien lourd mais en
fait pardon excusez moi si risque est
important dans ce que dit tiffany de ce
que dit kelly et isabelle s'en fait
c'est notre logiciel notre capacité toi
tu l'as pas pris comme une agression
tu l'as pas pris pour comme une
humiliation et francky organes kifani en
plus je sais qu'ils reconnaissent et
c'est une bonne pâte tiffany sincère je
le sais voilà c'est une amie depuis des
années tiffany actuelle elle rigole avec
et elle a des blagues de mecs en plus
tiffany donc c'est vrai que voilà l ceni
c'est une blague de wim escale à paris
pour une agression mais pour une
humiliation mais sauf qu'il ya des
filles qui le vivent super mal et quand
elles rentrent chez elles elles font des
tentatives de suicide elles deviennent
l'anorexie qu'elle devienne boulimique
elles sont mal dans leur nom mais c'est
pas la peine de marmonner dans dix ans
mais non mais non ça la peine si c'est
la réelle réunie